Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast produced by the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Kim Mills. Speaking of Psychology is a podcast for anyone with an interest in the science of psychology. We talk to psychological researchers, practitioners, and educators about any and every aspect of psychology and its application to the world around us. Dr. John Blythe is research associate at the Dawes Center for Future Crime at University College London, where he works on the Consumer Security Index part of the Petrus Internet of Things Research Hub. The Petrus Internet of Things Research Hub is a consortium of nine leading United Kingdom universities that are working together over three years to explore critical issues in privacy, ethics, trust, reliability,
您好，欢迎收听由美国心理学会制作的播客《心理学谈话》。我是主持人金·米尔斯。《心理学谈话》是一档面向所有对心理学科学感兴趣的人的播客。我们与心理学研究人员、从业者和教育工作者探讨心理学的方方面面及其在现实世界中的应用。约翰·布莱斯博士是伦敦大学学院未来犯罪研究中心的研究助理，他在那里从事彼得鲁斯物联网研究中心下属的消费者安全指数项目。彼得鲁斯物联网研究中心是由英国九所顶尖大学组成的联盟，他们正共同致力于在三年内探索隐私、道德、信任、可靠性等关键问题，
acceptability and security. Dr. Blythe previously held positions at the UCL Center for Behavior Change, the Department for Digital Culture, Media, and Sport, and Pact Lab at Northumbria University. His research focuses on exploring behavior change and cybersecurity. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Blythe. Thank you, for Havanaugh. So the Center for Future Crime, that's kind of an intriguing name. What does that mean to study future crime? So the Centre for Future Crime, we seek to focus essentially on horizon scanning what are the crimes that may arise from technological change or societal changes of the future and try to design out these risks through policy and regulation.
以及可接受性和安全性。布莱斯博士此前曾在伦敦大学学院行为改变中心、数字文化、媒体和体育部以及诺森比亚大学的Pact实验室任职。他的研究重点是探索行为改变和网络安全。感谢您加入我们，布莱斯博士。谢谢，哈瓦诺。那么，未来犯罪中心，这个名字听起来很有趣。研究未来犯罪意味着什么？未来犯罪中心，我们本质上寻求专注于地平线扫描，即技术变革或未来社会变革可能引发哪些犯罪，并试图通过政策和法规来设计规避这些风险。
So your research looks at security issues around the Internet of Things. Could you explain for people what the Internet of Things is? Certainly. So the Internet of Things is essentially everyday objects with the ability to connect to an exchange data over the Internet. It includes many different objects from Fitbits to Amazon Alexa, smartwatchers, all the way up to connected dishwashers, connected thermostats. And it's essentially the ability to use these products via the internet, and it gives us many different affordances such as, in the case of thermostats, it would be personalized heating services based on our behavior and habits. Why should we be concerned about the security around the internet of things? These devices are in our home. They may be connected to a boiler. they may be connected to a critical function in our house, such as a smogne alarm. And if these are interconnected, it means that a hacker can potentially exploit that device.
那么您的研究着眼于物联网周围的安全问题。您能为人们解释一下什么是物联网吗？当然。物联网本质上是具有通过互联网连接和交换数据能力的日常物品。它包括许多不同的物体，从Fitbit到亚马逊Alexa、智能手表，一直到联网洗碗机、联网恒温器。它本质上是通过互联网使用这些产品的能力，它为我们提供了许多不同的功能，例如，在恒温器的情况下，它将基于我们的行为和习惯提供个性化的供暖服务。我们为什么要担心物联网的安全？这些设备在我们的家里。它们可能连接到锅炉。它们可能连接到我们房子里的关键功能，例如烟雾报警器。如果这些设备互联，这意味着黑客可以潜在地利用该设备。
So if you think about the boiler example, it could potentially be hacked and the fire could be caused, and that could potentially lead to loss of life. So it's no longer just thinking about security and the privacy of our personal data, but it's also our well-being and potential life as well that can be exploited by these inherently insecure devices. And so what can be done to make them more secure? So at the minute, manufacturers simply aren't given enough consideration to the security of IoT. They are shipping these products out with essentially market failures.
所以如果你考虑锅炉的例子，它可能会被黑客入侵并导致火灾，这可能会导致生命损失。因此，这不再仅仅是考虑我们个人数据的安全和隐私，也是我们的福祉和潜在的生命，这些本质上不安全的设备也可能被利用。那么可以做些什么来使它们更安全呢？目前，制造商根本没有给予物联网安全足够的考虑。他们基本上是在带着市场失灵的情况下发布这些产品。
An example of some of these market failures are that a lot of these products can't be updated, so a vulnerability may be found in a product, but a large portion of the population may already purchase that product, and there's nothing the consumer can do about that. They now have a product that can't be updated anymore. And that's an example of one of the market failures. And what we call it in crime studies is a crime harvest, which is where an innovation is an adduced in society and there's not given adequate consequences of the crime. So the same thing happened when we started using vehicles.
这些市场失灵的一些例子是，许多这些产品无法更新，因此产品中可能会发现漏洞，但很大一部分人口可能已经购买了该产品，消费者对此无能为力。他们现在拥有一个无法再更新的产品。这就是市场失灵的一个例子。我们在犯罪研究中称之为犯罪收获，即当一项创新被引入社会，而没有给予足够的犯罪后果时。所以当我们开始使用车辆时，也发生了同样的事情。
Vehicles were designed, but they weren't designed with crime in mind. So what happens is that the criminals will start to reap the crime harvest. They recognize the potential opportunities that can be afforded by the lack of security of the innovation. And then what then happens is that we recognize the potential crime. consequences and then try to design out that crime. And what incentives do manufacturers have to make these products more secure at this point? At this point, there's very little incentive for manufacturers to take this seriously, which is why we're not really seeing manufacturers actually ship these products
车辆被设计出来，但它们在设计时并没有考虑到犯罪。所以发生的事情是，罪犯将开始收获犯罪成果。他们认识到创新缺乏安全性所能提供的潜在机会。然后发生的事情是，我们认识到潜在的犯罪后果，然后试图设计规避这种犯罪。那么制造商目前有什么动力使这些产品更安全呢？在这一点上，制造商认真对待这一点的动力很小，这就是为什么我们并没有真正看到制造商实际发布这些产品
with security and built, or in the UK we call it security by design, making sure that the security is baked into the product before you ship it out to consumers. What manufacturers are doing is to put all the burden on the consumer, expecting the consumer to protect the device, to change lots of passwords, to change all the settings, to essentially make the consumer protect the product rather than them shipping it with better security in the first place. So I understand that some of the research you've done is around labeling. Can you talk about what that means? How should these products be labeled?
时内置了安全性，或者在英国我们称之为设计安全，确保在将产品发布给消费者之前，安全性已经融入到产品中。制造商所做的是将所有负担都放在消费者身上，期望消费者保护设备，更改大量密码，更改所有设置，本质上是让消费者保护产品，而不是他们在第一时间发布时就提供更好的安全性。所以我了解到您所做的一些研究是关于标签的。您能谈谈这意味着什么吗？这些产品应该如何贴标签？
So the labeling scheme, which is called the Consumer Security Index in our project, is it's part of the UK government's initiative to improve the security of these products. So March this year, the UK government, specifically the Department for Digital Culture Medium Sport who are in charge of the SAP Security Policy, announced their Secure by Design for Consumer IOT report, which outlined the government measures for improving the security of these devices. Primarily, this was a court of practice that manufacturers should follow to ensure that these products are secured by design, but a supplementary measure was to explore the role. of the labelling scheme to first aid consumer choice because at the minute if you were
所以标签计划，在我们的项目中被称为消费者安全指数，它是英国政府改善这些产品安全性倡议的一部分。因此，今年3月，英国政府，特别是负责安全政策的数字文化媒体和体育部，宣布了他们的消费者物联网设计安全报告，该报告概述了政府改善这些设备安全性的措施。主要是，这是一项制造商应遵循的实践准则，以确保这些产品在设计上是安全的，但一项补充措施是探索标签计划的作用，以首先帮助消费者选择，因为目前如果你要
to go and buy a smart device for example a smart kettle from from a store there's no way for you to make a distinction between a secure product and insecure product so the label would help you make that choice and that decision the second intention of the label is to actually incentivize manufacturers to actually ship these products for security in the first place otherwise potentially risk reputational damage Do consumers have any idea at this point how insecure these products are? So a lot of research lately has suggested that the main barrier to adoption of the net of things is security and privacy concerns. We know that people are concerned about how their data may be used from these products and how that may be shared with third party companies.
去商店购买智能设备，例如智能水壶，你无法区分安全产品和不安全产品，因此标签将帮助你做出这种选择和决定。标签的第二个意图是实际上激励制造商在第一时间发布这些产品时就考虑到安全性，否则可能会面临声誉受损的风险。消费者目前是否知道这些产品有多不安全？最近的许多研究表明，采用物联网的主要障碍是安全和隐私问题。我们知道人们担心这些产品的数据如何被使用，以及如何与第三方公司共享。
But people aren't readily protecting themselves. So recently there's some stats by Cisco which found that 50% of people, see the value in IoT, only 10% of them actually think their data is secure, but 42% would continue using the products anyway. And it's what's called in the research a privacy paradox. People value their privacy, but they don't readily take any action to protect it. And there's a number of reasons for this. Botnet called the Morari Botnet, which was essentially hundreds and hundreds of thousands of exploited IoT devices that took down Netflix and Twitter and disrupted service access to these to these products. So it's not really happening to consumers so much at this point. They're
但人们并没有主动保护自己。最近思科有一些统计数据发现，50%的人看到了物联网的价值，只有10%的人认为他们的数据是安全的，但42%的人无论如何都会继续使用这些产品。这就是研究中所说的隐私悖论。人们重视隐私，但他们并不轻易采取任何行动来保护它。这有许多原因。名为Mirai僵尸网络的僵尸网络，本质上是成千上万个被利用的物联网设备，它们摧毁了Netflix和Twitter，并中断了对这些产品的服务访问。所以目前这对消费者来说并没有发生太多。他们
targeting major corporations from what you're seeing. They're mainly being used in what we would call a strategic risk where they're being used to take down a company or a service provider. Not so much. We haven't seen many attacks against consumers themselves. What should consumers be worried about? I mean, I'm just imagining, and I've said this before to my friends and colleagues, you know, you get a smart TV, you watch it, it watches you back. What's it doing with this? So the smart TV example, a couple of years ago, it was announced, well, it was revealed actually
从你所看到的情况来看，他们主要针对大公司。它们主要被用于我们所说的战略风险，即它们被用来摧毁一家公司或服务提供商。并不是很多。我们还没有看到多少针对消费者本身的攻击。消费者应该担心什么？我的意思是，我只是在想象，我之前也对我的朋友和同事说过，你知道，你买了一台智能电视，你看着它，它也看着你。它用这个做什么？所以智能电视的例子，几年前，它被宣布，好吧，实际上它被揭露了
that governments were potentially, well, the secret agencies of the government could potentially take sensitive data from the microphones in your smart TVs, which could reveal quite private conversations that you maybe have with family members. So there's that aspect to it, the privacy side of your life,
政府可能，好吧，政府的秘密机构可能从你的智能电视麦克风中获取敏感数据，这可能会揭示你可能与家人进行的相当私密的谈话。所以这方面，你生活中的隐私方面，
but also, like I said earlier, the safety side as well, if it's a children's toy, that's connected to the internet and a predator can potentially talk to your child. You know, that's very, that's very concern. Well, it sounds like there are implications for law enforcement, you know, where they might start asking if they can get records from these corporations,
但也像我之前说的那样，安全方面也是如此，如果是一个连接到互联网的儿童玩具，而掠夺者可能会与你的孩子交谈。你知道，这非常，非常令人担忧。好吧，听起来这对执法部门有影响，你知道，他们可能会开始询问是否可以从这些公司获取记录，
you know, say you're suspected of some kind of a crime. I mean, is this what consumers should be thinking about right now as they're purchasing these items? Yeah, and that has happened. There is an example of this in America where they have used data from a guy's Fitbit to show that he committed the murder of his wife. Scary stuff. Are there particular devices that we should be leery about?
你知道，假设你涉嫌某种犯罪。我的意思是，这就是消费者在购买这些物品时现在应该考虑的事情吗？是的，这种情况已经发生了。在美国有一个例子，他们使用了某人Fitbit的数据来证明他谋杀了他的妻子。可怕的事情。有没有我们应该警惕的特定设备？
And I'm thinking, I mean, one device that's out there right now that kind of, I have to say, gives me the creeps is the Amazon is distributing this lock system that you can supposedly can watch the delivery person arrive at your house, but basically that person can go in your house to leave a package. Is that the kind of thing we should be concerned? about. Yeah, so I think there's the concerns in terms of what what is the kind of device? Is it linked to something that's safety critical? For example, your front door, is it linked to something that may have a heating element, such as your boiler, or something that may be security
我在想，我的意思是，现在市面上有一种设备，我不得不说，让我感到毛骨悚然，亚马逊正在分发这种锁系统，你可以假设可以看着送货员到达你家，但基本上那个人可以进入你家留下包裹。这是我们应该担心的那种事情吗？关于。是的，所以我认为在设备种类方面存在担忧：它是否与安全关键的东西有关？例如，你的前门，它是否与可能具有加热元件的东西有关，例如你的锅炉，或者可能与安全有关的东西
related, such as your security cameras? I think people should be concerned about potentially what is it, what is the device linked to? What might it reveal about your house, your occupancy? For example, smart thermostats can let somebody know whether you're in the house or not, and that can be used to facilitate burglaries and other crimes as well. What are the next steps for you in terms of the research that you're doing? So we're looking to work with the UK government to develop a labelling scheme. It's going to be co-designed with both experts and consumers. So the consumer side of it is working with consumers to understand their preferences
相关，例如你的安全摄像头？我认为人们应该担心该设备可能与什么有关？它可能会揭示关于你房子的什么信息，你的入住情况？例如，智能恒温器可以让某人知道你是否在家，这可以被用来促进入室盗窃和其他犯罪。就你正在进行的研究而言，你的下一步是什么？所以我们正在寻求与英国政府合作开发一个标签计划。它将与专家和消费者共同设计。所以消费者方面是与消费者合作以了解他们的偏好
around what they want communicated on a label. What value do they see in a labelling scheme? Would it actually influence their behaviour? We'll also work on with experts to actually identify the underpinning technical content of the label because we're assessing objectively what security means. So all of our work is a lot more on the technical side of that. We'll also run a series of experimental studies to look at the design aspects of the label and whether that nudges people's behaviour and whether it would actually lead to them purchasing
关于他们希望在标签上传达什么。他们在标签计划中看到了什么价值？它会真正影响他们的行为吗？我们还将与专家合作，实际确定标签的基础技术内容，因为我们正在客观地评估安全性意味着什么。所以我们所有的工作在技术方面要多得多。我们还将进行一系列实验研究，以查看标签的设计方面，以及它是否会推动人们的行为，以及它是否会真正导致他们购买
a more secure product. Because ultimately we want the label to act as a market lever and as a market differentiator so that people, would be nudged to buying a more secure and private device in a one that isn't. But your work is focused on the UK, right? So, I mean, as far as the United States, are we doing anything similar here? So the UK government is in talks and collaboration with the USA because recognizing that actually these products are built across a global supply chain, they're not made primarily in the UK, they're made across the world,
更安全的产品。因为最终我们希望标签能起到市场杠杆和市场差异化的作用，这样人们就会被推动去购买更安全、更私密的设备，而不是一个不安全的设备。但你的工作重点是英国，对吧？所以，我的意思是，就美国而言，我们在这里做类似的事情吗？所以英国政府正在与美国进行会谈和合作，因为认识到实际上这些产品是在全球供应链中制造的，它们主要不是在英国制造的，它们是在世界各地制造的，
so it's very important that governments do collaborate. The UK government are looking at consumer IoT and have released reports, on this. What internet of things products do you have in your home? I don't own any. I guess you would know. Yeah. I don't want to, I mean, I've been very negative here. I don't want to scare people into not buying these products, but there is a huge potential crime risk associated with these devices. And particularly, I mean, the major manufacturers like Apple, Amazon, they do take security seriously. So if you're going to buy an IoT device, maybe go for one of the bigger providers rather than a cheaper one by a manufacturer who don't have a competency to a, to understand
所以政府进行合作非常重要。英国政府正在关注消费者物联网并发布了相关报告。你家里有什么物联网产品？我一个都没有。我想你会知道的。是的。我不想，我的意思是，我在这里一直非常消极。我不想吓唬人们不要购买这些产品，但与这些设备相关的巨大潜在犯罪风险。特别是，我的意思是，像苹果、亚马逊这样的大型制造商，他们确实认真对待安全性。所以如果你要购买物联网设备，也许选择更大的供应商，而不是由没有能力理解的制造商生产的更便宜的产品
security and be, bake it into the product. Given what's happened recently with Facebook, for example, can we trust these manufacturers? I mean, that's one of the biggest corporations in the world. And yet, you know, their data, who knows where it went. Exactly. I don't want to say don't trust these companies I think people I think what needs to happen is that there needs to be a better way for people to understand what's happening with their data and not to rely on people to read terms and conditions because it's just impossible to expect people to read that people just tick the box and then they move on so how are people are ever going to really be able to protect themselves with protect their
安全性，并将其融入产品中。鉴于最近Facebook发生的事情，例如，我们能信任这些制造商吗？我的意思是，那是世界上最大的公司之一。然而，你知道，他们的数据，谁知道它去了哪里。确实。我不想说不要信任这些公司，我认为人们，我认为需要发生的是，需要有一种更好的方式让人们了解他们的数据发生了什么，而不是依赖人们阅读条款和条件，因为期望人们阅读这些是不可能的，人们只是勾选框然后继续前进，所以人们怎么可能真正能够保护自己，保护他们的
personal data if we're relying on people to read those terms and conditions in the UK in the EU we have the upcoming GDPR legislation which is really good piece of legislation is going to put more power back to consumers around how their personal data is used and hopefully that will start to see attraction towards privacy being taken more seriously as we are more internet-connected. Anything else you'd like the public to know about the work that you're doing? Ultimately, we want the label scheme, because governments aren't regulating the other things, they're not enforced on manufacturers to actually ship these products with security built in.
个人数据，如果我们依赖人们阅读那些条款和条件？在英国，在欧盟，我们有即将到来的GDPR立法，这是一项非常好的立法，它将把更多的权力还给消费者，关于他们的个人数据如何被使用，希望随着我们互联网连接程度的提高，我们将开始看到人们对隐私被更认真对待的吸引力。你还有什么想让公众知道的关于你正在做的工作吗？最终，我们想要标签计划，因为政府没有监管物联网，他们没有强制制造商实际发布内置安全性的产品。
The UK government have said that if they are given manufacturers the opportunity to, to address this through the code of practice in the UK government. And if they aren't going to address it, then they might look at regulation for some manufacturers to do it. But in the absence of that, we need, for example, the labeling scheme
英国政府表示，如果他们给制造商机会，通过英国政府的实践准则来解决这个问题。如果他们不打算解决它，那么他们可能会考虑对一些制造商进行监管。但在没有这种情况的情况下，我们需要，例如，标签计划
to actually help people make a distinction between a secure and insecure product. Otherwise, there's no way for people to actually make that product choice unless they're gonna go out and research the security of the product, which the average consumer probably won't do. All right, well, you've given us a lot to think about. Yeah.
来真正帮助人们区分安全产品和不安全产品。否则，除非他们去研究产品的安全性，否则人们无法真正做出那种产品选择，而普通消费者可能不会这样做。好吧，你给了我们很多值得思考的东西。是的。
Thank you very much for joining us today, Dr. Bly. Thank you very much. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other great podcasts such as APA journals dialogue about the latest and most exciting psychological research and progress notes, which discusses the practice of psychology. You can find all APA podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, www.combeatingof Psychology.org to listen to more episodes. and see more resources on the topics we discuss. I'm Kim Mills with the American Psychological Association,
非常感谢您今天加入我们，布莱斯博士。非常感谢。心理学谈话是APA播客网络的一部分，其中包括其他很棒的播客，例如APA期刊对话，关于最新和最令人兴奋的心理学研究，以及进度记录，讨论心理学的实践。你可以在iTunes、Stitcher或任何你获取播客的地方找到所有APA播客。你也可以访问我们的网站www.combeatingof Psychology.org收听更多剧集，并查看关于我们讨论主题的更多资源。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯，
and this is Speaking of Psychology. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是心理学谈话。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。